I'm in iam it our car Chester Reinhold
Dyson over as if giving a mini five
doors is really a good idea
big adults with lots of luggage will
answer yes because this model is 16
centimeters longer and boasts 67 more
litres of cargo space but does it still
look good he thinks that's a matter of
taste it's like when an older relative
came to visit pinched your cheek and
said my how you've grown
they noticed the difference even if you
didn't over the years the original 3
door mini has grown up and gotten bigger
too almost unnoticed the design remains
virtually unchanged for the five-door
model it's chrome trimmed round
headlights and taillights the rounded
lines of its body and the typical mini
radiator grille make the 5-door version
look young compact and almost cute in
spite of its larger dimensions
it's enough to make you want to give the
car a pinch and say my how you've grown
I don't says the other question that
needs asking about the five-door many is
how does it drive differently from the
three-door the short answer is no there
is almost no difference the 5-door mini
still gives you the feeling of driving a
go-kart gut feeling so the 5-door
version not only looks like a mini it
feels like one too
inside things look much the same as in
the traditional three door mini as
always the workmanship is good and the
materials are of high quality the big
infotainment system can be operated
easily and intuitively using the knob in
the center console and all common
portable electronic devices can be
connected to it
the 5-door mini boasts more room for
passengers and their bags without making
many changes to the vehicles look I
don't says 7 centimetres of knee
clearance in the rear is quite a lot the
five-door is also six centimetres wider
and one centimeter higher than the
three-door model making for an
incredible feeling of space still the
middle seat in the back is suited only
for short shots looking at the technical
data the 75 kilowatt engine lets the car
accelerate from 0 to 100 kilometres an
hour and 10.1 seconds the manufacturer
says fuel consumption is 4.9 liters per
100 kilometers prices for the mini one
5-door started just under 19 thousand
euros in Germany drivers can select from
various driving modes including green
mid and sport choose the sport mode in
combination with a six-speed
transmission and you'll almost feel like
you're piloting a go-kart
Demming is I know says that the 5-door
mini is pretty cute and more of a mini
than its fellow countrymen or paceman
models but the list of optional extras
is extremely long and they can really
add up
really